قال المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه ان
جيش الاحتلال ارغم المدنيين على النزوح ثم
قصفهم وارتكب مجازر بحقهم 48 مره واعتبر
حرب الاباده الجماعيه ضد المدنيين في
القطاع وصمه عار على جبين الانسانيه وطالب
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه المجتمع
الدولي بوقف الاباده الجماعيه التي
يرتكبها الاحتلال في حق
المدنيين
معنا من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن اطلعنا على
تفاصيل المشهد الميداني وكذلك على الصعيد
الانساني نعم محمود قبل قليل مقاتلات
حربيه اسرائيليه اخترقت حاجز الصوت هنا في
مدينه خان يونس يتزامن ذلك مع اندلاع
وتجدد الاشت باكات مجددا في عدد من
المحاور في المتاخمه لوسط مدينه خان يونس
وايضا في المحاور الشرقيه المعتاده لعلنا
نسمع اختراق مقاتلات حربيه اسرائيليه
لحاجز الصوت مجددا هنا في مدينه خانس مع
تجدد الاشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قبل قليل
مدفعيه جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اطلقت عدد
من القذائف على منطقه حوس في مدينه
خانيونس هذه هذا القصف اصفر عن استشهاد
امراه وطفلتها وصلوا الى مستشفى ناصر هنا
في مجمع عناصر الطبي ايضا الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه دمرت قبل نحو ساعتين
من الان مربعا سكنيا يضم عددا من المنازل
في حاره وافي في منطقه الكتيبه وهي
المنطقه التي تشهد منذ اكثر من اسبوع
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه بين المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى قصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي استهدف مبنى جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر وهذا المبنى ياوي الاف النازحين
الفلسطينيين ما ادى الى استشهاد فلسطيني
واصابه العشرات بجروح متفاوته الى جانب
قصف منزل بالقرب من المستشفى ادى الى
الحاق اضرار ماديه كبيره في هذه المنطقه
في وسط القطاع القصف المدفعي المكثف من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يستهدف
مختلف مخيمات منطقه الوسط وتحديدا مخيم
مغازي والبريج وايضا مخيم النصيرات قبل
قليل وصل جثمان شهيد وعدد من الاصابات من
داخل مخيم المغازي نتيجه قصف اسرائيلي
بالاضافه الى انه منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر
بدا الاف الفلسطينيين من سكان منطقه
المغازي وايضا مخيم النصيرات ومنطقه
الزوايده بالنزوح باتجاه المنطقه الجنوبيه
بعد لله كانت كثيفه وحافل بالغارات الجويه
والاحزمه الناريه التي شنتها طائرات جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على مختلف المناطق في
وسط القطاع الاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه في
المنطقه الوسطى وكذلك المنطقه الجنوبيه
الاف النازحين يهرعون لمراكز
الانح عذرا مؤمن كتائب القسام تقول اننا
دمرنا دبابه صهيونيه من نوع مركاه بعبوه
شواف غرب المغازي وسط قطاع غزه
تفضل
نعم محمود نتحدث عن نزوح الالاف منذ ساعات
الصباح من المنطقه الوسطى الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه يلجؤون الى مراكز الاواء مراكز
الاواء ممتلئه عن بكره ابيها بالاف مئات
الاف النازحين لا يجدون مكان يوون اليه
يضطرون للمبيت في
الشوارع وسط اوضاع صعبه يعيشونها وسط عدم
توفر الامكانيات في المنطقه الوسطى هناك
نقص حاد في الغذاء والماء وكذلك الدواء
وايضا في المنطقه الجنوبيه لا تتوفر
مقومات اساسيه لاواء النازحين في ظل
الاجواء البارده تحديدا في ساعات الليل
الاشتباكات على الصعيد الميدان اشتباكات
متواصله هنا في خانيونس في كافه المحاور
المحاور القريبه من وسط البلد هناك حسب
افاد ما افادنا به شهود عيان قبل قليل في
ساعات الصباح الباكر حاولت دبابات واليات
جيش الاحتلال التقدم الى شارع جلال وسط
مدينه خان يونس لكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تصدت لها م اضطرها واجبرها على التراجع
الى الاماكن التي كانت تتمركز فيها في
محيط مقر بلديه خانيونس وايضا منطقه
المحطه والكتيبه وايضا الاشتباكات تتواصل
كما هو الحال في مخيم المغازي الذي شهد
توغلا اسرائيليا في عدد من المناطق شرقيه
المخيم بالاضافه الى الاشتباكات المتواصله
في الاطراف الشرقيه من مخيم البريج وايضا
المحور الشمالي للمخيم قوات الاحتلال تمنع
سيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الدفاع المدني من
الوصول الى عدد من المناطق في مخيمي
البريج والمغازي والحديث عن عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف
انتشالهم من تلك المناطق وايضا المواطنون
اهالي الضحايا لا يستطيعون الوصول الى تلك
المناطق من شده الاشتباكات التي تدور في
محوري المغازي والبريج في وسط القطاع مؤمن
الشرافي مراسل الجزيره كان معنا من مستشفى
ناصر في خان يونس شكرا لك
مؤمن